Sudan has been a member of the
intergovernmental Authority on
development or egad since it was
established in
1996 but after weeks of tension with the
regional block stemming from differences
on how egat should handle Sudan's
conflict that is now in its 9th month
Sudan's foreign Ministry says it's
suspending its membership the eard has
invited the the leader of rhf Rebel
group for the summit he he Summits are
for heads of states and governments so
this is uh this is against the charter
of igad this is unacceptable to Sudan
Sudan had already withdrawn from egide
Le talks to end the conflict describing
it as an internal issue the fighting has
killed more than 12,000 people and
displaced 7.5 million according to the
United Nations EAD has been trying to
bring together the leaders of the two
wearing sides the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces for a
face-to-face meeting it had hoped that
would lead to a ceasefire agreement
followed by political talks that would
put the country back on its transition
to democracy but in December Sudan
objected to a communicate issued by the
blog regarding potential talks between
the two leaders it said no meeting would
take place prior to the rsf withdrawing
from civilian homes and from cities it
took over during the conflict egad was
the only Regional Block in the past few
weeks that has been trying to end the
conflict in Sudan after talks in jeda
failed to reach a ceasefire with Sudan's
government now suspending its membership
any hopes that those affected by the
conflict have for a diplomatic solution
is also in doubt hia Morgan Al jazer
Harum make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz